Challenge five standard oh did we have a
tight game before ah
I was playing white against tea night
and I had a not so good position against
tea night he played the Sicilian against
me
I'm throwing it back all right this is a
veteran akov Sicilian or raw sleemo
Moscow no open Sicilian with what to
follow especially cough Sicilian it
takes not so great I'm pretty sure
because it just repairs the weakened
square on d5 okay am i able to just get
in d5 now okay I'm still gonna run with
this and I'll take with my night yeah
that's the right one to go with take
with the night even though this night is
pinned and I really have to worry about
this guy this night I need to win more
than just a pawn hmm is this um already
slightly miss played on white with the
Nightbeat three move I think in previous
games I had I did recapture on d5 with
my queen I think going with the night is
better though so I'm wondering which
piece to capture the night with I take
with the Bishop I'm giving up the bishop
hair I take with the night I get the
damaged structure and I keep the keep my
Bishop around I'm gonna go with that I'd
be happy to see Bishop takes I think
pawn takes is best just to get the move
back there'd be double pawns no matter
what I would like to just have have the
move back here where I can get more
development instead of having to react
to
Bishop attack so let's see what our
white does follow up moves something
with castle my light square bishop I'm
not sure where I want to go Bishop here
is maybe best reinforce my Center
prepare for maybe some pond push it's
the right spot also I could view it as
keeping this diagonal opened so that my
Queen can maybe come out to h4 if I
castle a queen h5 could be quite
annoying this bishop is a pain although
wait a second if I Castle in Queen h5 I
could play f5 yeah I think that that's a
good resource a good way to defend
initially I was thinking g6 would be
needed not h6 because of some tactics
both bishops are pointing at my king
side so adding another piece to the mix
could just turn out to be overwhelming
so that's why I'm I took pause on this
move eleven about me castling and
instead of getting caught up in the you
know just the routine development
development development well I need to
be aware of the possibilities that white
has I believe I just take otherwise this
pawn push and then something with f6 is
a giant pain so let me take and then as
a follow-up what should I be doing
take the dark square bishop and then
play my knight here maybe whoa there
could be some issues on this I can get
fishing pulled watch out for that
fishing Paul Bishop takes rook takes
Knight here Bishop takes Bishop Bishop
takes pawn king takes Queen check came
here Knight here it's just it's not
working I'm not there in time there'd be
to the rook can clean if trained on this
file are threatening two different main
two's h7 and h8 my knight could only
defend against one if it came to g6 at
the end of it Bishop takes rook takes
Knight here is met with Bishop takes
pawn King takes at the very least
there's Queen check and then picks off
my knight so what do I do as an
adjustment I think I take here first and
then play here as a defense so that
there's no Bishop sack to be where I
really did want to play this but I think
it fails tactically this is an ideal
dark square an ideal flight square in
the sense that it's opposite
this light square bishop can't control
here I do have to be cautious about this
Knight maybe getting to this square c5
here here or something but that runs
into some trouble with Queen b6 and it's
in a pin I think I just want to get both
minor pieces off this knight in
particular if he's off the board I'm not
gonna have to worry about these weak
squares so much let's see
two-twenty and slightly under two
minutes okay now this is just coming
with the fork I'm gonna go with that
I'm the queen and the bishop I might uh
end up repairing this structure but I
think I could still stand better with
just maybe putting pressure on these two
pawns they're almost like it's almost
like a hanging pawn structure there
might be possibilities for a check-in
Knight g4 controlling these two dark
squares we're now not at at time 150
each about and now what do we do here
okay
I really just want to take that [ __ ] up
or is there something better hmm
Queen here I'll end up in a pin
eventually that's not a good one if I go
here there's another pin
I really can't maintain my night here I
want to maintain I have to play f6 but
that seems to weakening let's get rid of
it okay now what the Queen's are off I
win this ending
I gotta go quick there's a check know
about Bishop here immediately I'm gonna
try it and then whoa oh I thought they
might have disconnected I didn't know
why they were rattling off that next
move right away
so I didn't want night here and I'm also
thinking about Bishop here but now not
on the night in the pond
so a rook and pawn endgame maybe
okay now that Knight does not have a
move put pressure on this and then rook
c4 to a4 look c4 to a4 pressure on this
pond maybe but rook on a3 and before
it's kicked away let's stop this pawn
from pushing it is past after all if
it's if it has pressure placed on I
defend it like this not the not the best
place to be having to defend that bishop
but I have to work with it
okay there's a bishop moves here not far
off let's go with this I don't know that
the knight could still move bishop
here's the threat skewer
30 seconds left easy to go wrong go with
this to avoid a rope check I'm a knight
twice pawn pushes available
okay now the knight is pinned this is
hit twice and I think as a follow-up I
do to pawn pushes and I get this pawn
and then actually I'm on the knight and
then this pond now this is a one King
and pawn endgame this is a pin that my
opponent cannot get out of the king
could only go to one of these two
squares but I just keep this in here
actually I just pushed these pawns to
victory lane keep your opponent in a pin
no matter where the King goes I just
keep pushing these pawns and actually I
take here still keeping this pin to the
last second don't take the pin push
again and then take and then promote in
that order no time no time no time no
time
actually I could grab that take that and
then get this pawn all right good game
tonight let's back up and flip and see
about this move out of this Vesna cough
I don't know about the Nightbeat three
move I think black is I don't know it
seems like maybe black is equalizing
after Bishop b4 and getting in d5 I'm
feeling pretty comfortable here on the
black side this night is out of play
these guys are a bit messed up and I'm
pretty sure I have a good response to an
immediate Queen out with f5 and then
there's there's some worry about you
know am I going to push efore f4 at some
point
well not f4 because of age 7 but
something with E 4 and then F 4 and then
f3 maybe who knows so I I just I think
night b5 is again the most testing but
even running with this line I think it
got to be a pretty equal okay yeah this
is I mean okay Bishop a little bit of an
advantage maybe but maybe don't even
play here I wonder if something like c4
or I'll get your King up immediately
King f2 and if I put pressure on this
pond then you play C 4 I put pressure on
this pawn your king is already in a spot
to garden maybe C 4 is the better pawn
push controlling these light squares and
still keeping available the 94 move to
get my Bishop c4 maybe is a little bit
better in this endgame
maybe just some rough thoughts but it
seems like I do have a lot of pressure
now I can pivot about on c4 make use of
a 4 and these pawns are constantly under
fire and the white white is having to
defend so maybe just one tweak with this
is the c4
see for instead of the D for moving that
ending but okay good game what